ilk
[Müzik]
öncelikle hepiniz hoşgeldiniz biraz
heyecanlı olabilirim yapacağım hata
olursa şimdiden affedin beni
ben Hayat hikayemi başlayayım benim
hayat hikayem rutin kontroller için
gittiğim hastanede yani dahiliye
bölümüne gitmiştim istenen yanlış bir
tahlil sonucu başladı Yani yanlışlıkla
rutin kontrollerin içerisinde istememiş
olan bir hormon testinin sekreterin
yanlışlıkla işaretlemesi sonucu başladı
sonuçlar çıktığında diğerleri iyiyken o
yanlış istenen teslim çok yüksek
olduğunu gördük Doktor beni Allah
ailesine yönlendirdi İlk başta ben çok
şaşırdım ne alaka dedim bir hormon testi
ile beyin cerrahisine ne alakası
olabilir dedim şöyle söyledi beynimizde
tümörler olabileceğini ve bu Tomor
tümörlerin hormonların salınımını boza
bileceğini söyledi Ben çok korktum
koştur koştur beyin cerrahisine gittim
beyin cerrahisi emar istedi Arman
çekildi ve sonucumun raporumun dışarıdan
gelen bir doktor tarafından 2-3 gün
içerisinde okunacağını söylediler o
dönem ben hastanede çalışıyordum Aynı
çalıştım hastanede yaptırdığım için bazı
şeyler biraz daha kolay oluyordu benim
için bir gün Yemekhaneye çıkacağız emar
bölümünden çıkmamız yasak Çünkü oradan
yatan hastaların İş çıkışı oluyor benim
ayağım istemsizce beni oraya çekti ve
oradan gitmek istedim ben oraya adımımı
attığım anda emardaki Arkadaş beni
çağırdı doktorun burada olduğunu ve
Raporum abaka bileceğini söyledi O an
Op.Dr raporuna baktı inceledi ve şunu
söyledi bana 2.2 milim adenomun olduğunu
Yani halk arasındaki ismi tümör ya da
kitle her ne derseniz ama bunların Tabii
yüzde doksandokuz iyi huylu oluyor bunu
söyledi bana
Ben dedim raporun ne zaman çıkar rapora
gerek yok dedi sen bunu doktoruna paylaş
o seni gereken yerlere yönlendirsin dedi
Daha sonra ben gittim doktoruma durumu
anlattım Beni Akdeniz Üniversitesi
Hastanesi'ne sevk etti Çünkü o testler
Alanya Devlet Hastanesi gibi küçük bir
hastanede yapılmıyordu ben bu testleri
verdim yaptırdım sonuçlardan bir tanesi
küçük bir birimi yüksekti önemsemedim
dedim ki Bence Önemli bir şey değil
attım onu sonra hayatıma devam ettim
aradan biraz zaman geçti beni başhekim
asistanlığına göre evlendirdiler yine
Orada bizim yapmamız gereken ve yapmamız
gereken işler vardı Ama ben yine bir şey
merak ederek yapmam gereken bir şey
elime attım ve farktan gelen bir kağıdı
elime aldım orada Hipofiz adenomu ndan
ameliyat olmuş bir arkadaşın raporunu
gördüm ve çok şaşırdım Çünkü bana da
Hipofiz adenomu olduğunu söylemişlerdi
ama ben önem sevmemiştim Neyse ben bunu
bilinçaltıma atmışım unutmuşum daha
sonra aradan iki buçuk ay geçti ve bu
ameliyat olan kızla karşılaştık Ben
dedim ki geçmiş olsun doktorun Bana da
aynı şeyi söyledi dedim sonuç nedir diye
söylediğimde bana
bu gidip tedavi olup olmadığımı sordu
Ben de böyle böyle dedim önemsemedim
dedim Sonra beni bana hastalığın
gerçeklerini anlattı hastalığımla beni
Aslında bir nevi Yüzleştir di sonra ben
korktum ve tekrardan
yola çıktım Akdeniz Üniversitesi'nde
tekrardan testi yaptırayım diye gittim
tekrardan kanları mı verdim Bu defa
benim o önemseme bu dükkanların
tahlillerin hepsi yükselmişti tekrar
emar çektiler emarda o 2.2 limacon var
dedikleri yer görüntülenemiyor karanlık
çıkıyor ama adnok soru işaretleri net
bir şey yok
sonra benden o daha önce çektirdim
emarın raporunu istediler ben o emarın
raporunu istediğimde şu yazıyordu
raporda hastada herhangi bir klinik
bulgu gözlenmemiştir Şimdi ben
düşünüyorum Eğer ben tesadüfen emara
gitmeseydim O doktorla karşılaşmasaydım
o rapora istinaden hareket etseydim
hastalığımı asla öğrenecektim üzerine
gitmeyecektin ya da ufaksa bakmasaydı o
kızın hasta olduğunu bilmeyecek Tim ve
onunla karşılaştığımda bu soru
sormayacaksın ve yine bilmeyecek Team
tesadüfler zinciri beni birazcık
hastalığıma götürdüm daha sonra benden
seri halde birtakım testler devam ediyor
ama tam olarak şey tanı konulamıyor i
bir tek seferde 12 tüp kan aldıklarını
Biliyorum başımın dönüp halsizleşti mi
biliyorum tek başıma gidip geliyorum
Alanya'da yaşıyorum bu arada Alanya'dan
Antalya'ya sürekli git gel git gel Çok
fazla yorulmuştum çok fazla yıpranmıştı
Man son her seferinde beni zaten heyet
sevk ediyorlar yani tek başına karar
veremiyor hocalar en son dediler ki hiç
unutmuyorum bir tane Dr Sema Hanım dedi
sonunda dedi hastalığının tanısı konuldu
dedi bir benim hastalığım dedim bana
şunu söyledi akromegali
akromegali nedir dedim ben öncelikle
size akromegalinin ne olduğunu anlatayım
Aslında Ender olan bir durum değil Bu
akromegali hastalığı Biz anne karnına
düştüğümüz andan itibaren duyma hormonu
salgılanıyor uzun larımız vücudumuz
büyüyebilirsin diye Eğer bu çocukluk
ergenlik dönemimizde yeterince
salgılanmaz ne güzellik ya çok fazla
salgılanırsa yıkan çizim yani devrik
Eğer büyüdük 25 30 yaşına geldik bu
hormon fazla salgılanmaya devam ediyor
Bu defa akromegali hastalığı ortaya
çıkıyor Nedir sonucu bir vücudu sürekli
apsut büyümeleri zorluyor iç organları
büyütüyor el ayak numaralarını büyütüyor
vesaire vesaire
akromegalinin ne olduğunu Tabi ben
bilmiyorum doktor bana akromegalide dedi
akromegalinin nedir dediğimde bana şunu
söyledi Bu hastalık erken öldürür
Ben orada kaldım Oh kurduğu cümlenin
arkasına söylediği hiçbir şey duymadım
çok fazla şey söyledi ama inanın
Hiçbirini hatırlamıyorum Çünkü bana
orada söylenebilecek en uç iyi
söylemişti doktorun yanından çıktığında
ağlıyordum eve gittim otobüsteyim
ağlıyorum eve çıktım ağlıyorum gece
12.00 oldu ben hala ağlıyorum Aynanın
karşısına geç de kendime baktım Yüzüm
Gözüm şişmiş haldeydi Sonra baktım
kendime dedim ki
sen dedim Niye ağlıyorsun Sema dedim sen
dedim ağladığın zaman bu hayat sana
dedim Artık bir şey mi verecek aksine
dedim eksileri olacak dedim neydi Senin
hayallerin dedim neydi küçüklük
Hayallerim dedim madem erken öleceksin
dedim madem bu hastalık erken öldürür
dedim o zaman dedim ayağa kalkıyorsun ve
hayallerini yaşamak için dedim Düğmeye
basıyorsun dedim ve o gün kalktığımda
çok güçlüydüm kendimi kurt gibi
hissettim çok güçlü uyandım her
zamankinden daha güçlüydüm sonra benim
çocukluk hayalim olan dağcılık Beş
yaşındaki hayalimde dağcılık için
araştırmalara koyuldum Antalya'ya
yerleştim O süre zarfında Aslında benim
bu sporu yapamamış olmamın sebebi
Alanya'da Bununla ilgili bir kulüp yoktu
yani yapabileceğim bir alan yok daha
fazla izin gerekiyordu bunun için bunun
yapıldığı bir yere taşınmak gerekiyordu
Ben de Antalya'ya taşındım birincisi
dağcılık İkincisi de şehir şehir gezmek
önce ülkemi gezmek ülkemi tanımak sonra
dünyayı gezmek henüz kuvvetten dolayı
yeterince bütün şehirleri tamamlayamadım
için zaten yurtdışı çıkışları da kısıtlı
O hayalimi henüz gerçekleştiremedim ama
Şehir şehir Gezmeye devam ediyorum
dağcılık sporunu yapmaya devam ediyorum
ve sizi size şunu anlatmak istiyorum
Neden bunu giydim Belki biraz değişik
gelmiş olabilir bu benim tırmanış
kemerim dağcılıkta biz bunları giyiyoruz
ipi buradan giriyoruz bir tane
emniyetiniz oluyor Lider tırmanıcı önden
gidiyor ipi arkadan Emniyeti veriyor
şimdi ben tırmanıyorum nasıl hayata
tutundum
tırmanıyorum ilk ara istasyona geliyorum
Ekspresi mi takıyorum ip içerisinden
geçiriyorum Ondan sonra biraz daha ve
hayatımda karşıma bir olumsuzluk çıkıyor
ve ben düşüyorum Bana Doktor diyor ki
ameliyat olacaksın ben orada birçok
eziyorum düşüyorum bu Ekspress beni
tutuyor bu eksilmez Benim hayallerim her
bir Ekspress benim hayalim oldu
arkadaşlarım oldu çevrem oldu ben
tırmanırken bunlara tutuldum Ve sonunda
ben hep bunlar beni zirveye ulaştırdı
sonrasında şöyle birşey oldu
a Tabi bu tedavi süreci devam ediyor ben
dağcılıkla uğraşıyorum bir taraftan ama
tedavi sürecimde devam ediyor sonra bana
ameliyat kararı çıktı o kısmı anlatayım
size
Bunun için iyi bir doktor araştırmamız
gerekir Çünkü
Türkiye'de budu ameliyatı yapabilen çok
fazla doktor yok Ben doktor buldum her
şey hazırladım herşey hazır kendini
psikolojik olarak da hazırladım Tabii ki
çok fazla riski olan bir ameliyattır O
yüzden 8 masada kalan bir ameliyat ama
ben başka tedavisi olmadığı için buna
rağmen bu ameliyatı kabul ettim ama neye
kabul ettim defalarca emar çekildi Benim
beynim içerisine girip alacakları bölüp
karanlık olan 5 tane soru işareti olan
bir bölümü gidecekler kitle var mı
arayacaklar Aslı Benimki de biraz
delilik Çünkü net bir şey yok orası
görüntülenemiyor Neyse ameliyattan önce
benden bir takım seri halde tahliller
istendi bu tahlilleri yaptırdım Ben
sonraki gün Ben ameliyat önlüğünü
giyeceğim ve ameliyathaneye gideceğimi
Beklerken Doktor geldi dedi ki ameliyat
iptal dedim ben neden neden iptal çünkü
dedi o görüntülenemeyen karanlık bölge
var ya dedi orası görüntülendi ve sizin
Hipofiz ip ofisinizde hiçbir şekilde
adım ahitle eder bir şey rastlanmadı
dedi hipofisis Temiz Evet şimdi buna
Benim ailem çok sevindi etrafımdakiler
Herkes çok sevindi ama anormal olan bir
durum vardı ortada Çünkü
ben şöyle düşündüm birisi var yürüyor
ayakları yok yürüyor ama nasıl yürüyor
bilmiyoruz benim bir hastalığın var
testlerim yüksek çıkıyor Aslı testleri
yüksek çıkması için o kitlenin olması
gerekiyor kitle o testleri bozacak yani
çünkü hormonların salındığı bölgede var
olan bir kitle bu bu ama kitle yok
tahliller yüksek baskı altına alınamıyor
ilaç tedavisi yok Tedavisi mümkün
olmayan bir hastalık orta tek tedavi
yöntemi var o da kitleyi ameliyatla yok
etmek Şimdi benim tek tedavi olan
yöntemi O da ortadan kalktı Ben çok
üzüldüm
endokrine konsültasyon atmasını istedim
Sonuç olarak endokrine konsantrasyon
atıldı beni tekrar heyete çağırdılar ve
doktor evetten çıktığında de böyle
alkışladı beni dedi ki tebrik ediyorum
Sema Hanım dedi Ender vaka olarak
kayıtlarımıza geçmiş bulunmaktasınız
dedi kitlesi olmayan ama testi baskı
altına alınamayan hormonları yüksek olan
bir akromegaliye Hastasıyım o süreçten
sonra gerçekten Tamam ben şu bilgiyi
Biliyorum bu hastalığın beni 70-80
yaşlarına kadar getirmeyeceğini
biliyorum Hadi geleceğimizi bilemeyiz
Belki de farklı bir teknolojik şey
ortaya çıkacak ve biz bunu yeneceğiz onu
da bilmiyorum ama bildiğim tek bir şey
var gerçekten Şu kısacık hayatımızda
hangimizi kim olursa olsun ne kadar
yaşayacağımızı Hiçbirimiz bilmiyoruz Ben
şunu biliyorum yaşadığım her dakikanın
değerini biliyorum aldığım her nefesin
değerini Biliyorum ve hayat bana şunu
öğretti Aslolan gerçekten hayatımızı ne
kadar yaşadığımız değil bu süreyi ne
kadar kaliteli yaşadığımızda Ama ben çok
teşekkür ediyorum